Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu Raumzeit, dem Podcast über Raumfahrt und andere kosmische Angelegenheiten. Mein Name ist Tim Pritlove.
Und heute,
weil ich mal wieder aufreisen und äh konnte mich endlich mal wieder an äh Orte des Geschehens begeben. Das ist auch sehr schön.
Und zwar hat mich der Weg geführt nach Darmstadt da wo ich schon so oft war und auch immer wieder gerne hinkomme nämlich an das europäische,
Raumfahrtkontrollzentrum, das ESOG, also die Niederlassung der Esa,
in Deutschland, sie ist ja quer über Europa verteilt und hier werden die Flugzeuge, also die Raumflugzeuge gesteuert, die äh ja uns den ganzen Tag über den Kopf fliegen.
Und warum bin ich hier? Ja, ist es ein ganz besonderes äh Thema, was vielleicht so auf den ersten Blick erstmal gar nicht so viel mit den ganzen Folgen zu tun hat, die wir bisher so gemacht haben, aber von dem ich denke,
dass es äh trotzdem Relevanz hat, denn wir möchten heute eigentlich über ein Spiel sprechen. Konkret über das Curble Space Programm
und dazu begrüße ich erstmal meinen Gesprächspartner, nämlich den äh Bruno Tischer Dessusa. Hallo.
Ähm du arbeitest hier bei der ESA, beim ESOG,
Aber wie es hier so ein bisschen meine Art, das muss ich echt mal fragen, wie bist du denn zur Raumfahrt gekommen? Bist du äh auch so einer von diesen jungen Begeisterten, die schon irgendwie,
Mit fünf Jahren mit Planeten in der Hand durch die Gegend gelaufen sind oder was hat dich getrieben.
Ich kann mich äh erinnern, dass ich so sieben Jahre alt war. Da kam ein Fernseher diese Seriengalaktiker.
Mhm. Battle, Battle Star Galaktika. Oh ja.
Battlestar geleitet. Das das war was mich am meisten beeinflusst hat. Ich will ich habe ich habe meinen Vater dann gesagt, ja ich will Astronaut werden.
Und da hat er gesagt, ja, du bist leider Portugiese, das das geht gar nicht.
Hättest dann lieber Amerikaner oder Russen geboren äh sein können.
Das war ich leider nicht. Aber dann, okay, ich aber ich war begeistert von dieser Galaktike. Ich habe mir immer so diese diese Raumschiffe gezeichnet im Papier, in der Schule.
Und ja, er hatte schon Planen wie, wie man das alles mit Schrott irgendwann bauen könnte,
und äh ja, aber ich musste diese Traume dann ein bisschen anpassen und dann äh als ich schon ungefähr dreizehn Jahre alt war, kam in in Kino, kam Topgun,
und dann habe ich's, okay. Äh Kampfjetflieger, das kann ich. Das gibt's sog.
Das kann ich tun,
man weiß nicht, vielleicht irgendwann. Und dann ich hatte alles dann vorbereitet, ich würde dann äh ändern meine Schule kommen und dann in die Luftmacht in äh gehen und dann fliegen lernen,
Aber genau in dem Jahr, als ich dann ähm bewerben musste, am Ende meiner Schuhe, in äh meiner äh Gymnasium,
da kam die Möglichkeit in Portugal gab's zum ersten Mal so äh als Fach ähm Luft und Raumfahrtingenieur. Und dann habe ich.
Erste Mal.
Das erste Mal. Das war ja, es gab alles anderes, so der Elektriker oder ähm Mechaniker oder.
Aber wer äh Luft und Raumfahrt gab's zum ersten Mal in zweiundneunzig.
Und dann habe ich geahnet, lieber Bauen als äh Fliegen ist schön, aber dann dann sitzt man nur den ganzen Tag in Cockpit,
Und irgendwann muss das langweilig sein. Äh aber bauen, da kann man immer was Neues ähm sich denken lassen.
Mhm. Also es war Luft, Luft und Raumfahrt in als Luft- und Raumfahrtingenieur. Mhm.
Jahresstudium, denn.
In Lissabon nehme ich an. Mhm.
Und ja äh habe ich Glück gehabt und könnte in die, das waren nur so dreißig Leuten in erster Eingang äh ja,
und da war ich mit dabei und war nicht leicht, aber ich habe durchgemacht,
Und dann am Anfang gab's keine Jobs. Die dachten damals, die haben so ein kleines Satellit gebaut, die erste portugiesische Satellit und dachten, jetzt kommt unsere ganze große Weltraumindustrie jetzt voran und kann nicht, gab's wirklich,
als in äh siebenundneunziger sich fertig war. Da muss ich zu Computerscience, zu IT,
Da habe ich äh vier Jahren als Entwickler gearbeitet, Softwareentwicklung.
Und dann äh habe ich geendet, ging ich zu ähm Mobil Telekom, habe ich da zwei Jahren gearbeitet als in so in Marketing.
Produktentwickler habe ich äh so Requiments für neue äh Dienste geschrieben und so.
Dass er schon ganz schön weit weg vom Astronauten, ne? Ja.
Und okay, aber er war zufrieden, es war alles gut und die Technik war schön und hab immer diese Kreativität dabei, um Sachen zu zu entwickeln,
Aber dann ähm diese Filme, wo ich war, wurde von von der Konkurrenz gekauft und zugemacht, habe ich so Entschädigungen bekommen und ja, was jetzt,
Da war eine Freund von mir aus der Uni und der hatte einen Auftrag von der äh spanischen Firma eine Branche in Portugal zu bauen,
Und das war ähm die die hatten Software für Weltraum entwickelt,
Und er hat gefragt, wirst du bei uns in dem Spiel auch? Warum nicht? Und unser erster Auftrag war hier bei Airsog,
als Tester und Integrationsingenieur zu zwei Jahren,
zu kommen und das zu durchführen. Okay, zwei Jahren in in Deutschland. Ich war früher drei Jahre, als ich angefangen habe, war ich schon drei Jahre in Holland und in Holland ist die wie sagt man auf Deutsch Reputation, die.
Reputation der deutschen nicht ganz hoch und sagen okay nach Deutschland zwar ist nur zwei Jahren.
Die doofen, langweiligen Deutschen.
Ich habe so genau an der Grenze mit Deutschland gewohnt in Holland und da war so immer so die Sache ein bisschen gespannt. Und,
Ja, zwei Jahren in Deutschland, aber es ist äh Essock. Äh es ist die europäische Weltraumagentur, es man kann nicht nein sagen. Also.
Macht man das mal.
Wenig gekommen.
Das ist ja hier auch so ein kleines Raumschiff, also ihr so,
super international. Du bist ja das beste äh Beispiel und bei Labe eben nicht das Einzige. Ich habe hier schon mit so vielen Leuten gesprochen, die aus aller Welt hierher gekommen sind und äh Englisch ist ja hier sowieso äh eigentlich so die Tagessprache,
da fühlt man sich eigentlich auch erstmal gar nicht so, als wäre man in Deutschland.
Genau, genau, die ersten Jahren äh lernt man fast gar kein Deutsch, alles sprechen, Englisch,
und ähm aber okay. Mittlerweile habe ich eine deutsche Familie auch äh äh und das musste ich dann irgendwann.
Du bist gekommen, um zu bleiben sozusagen.
Ja, das wusste ich gar nicht damals. Das war sieben, äh das war zweitausenddrei, als ich hingekommen war. Und wusste ich nicht, ich dachte zwei Jahren, aber kurz danach habe ich meine jetzige Frau kennengelernt und und dann.
Was geschehen. Okay.
Und dann irgendwann war ich auch bei Esel dann fest angestellt und will nicht von von testen und sagt der Entwicklung nach ob ob Operations umgewandelt erstmal mit Vinus Express, das war ein sehr lieb nach Venus.
Habe ich lange gearbeitet, fast neun Jahren,
und dann zu Solarbitter, da war damals in Entwicklungsphase, ganz am Anfang haben wir da dann Konzepten entwickelt für für Operationen von,
diese Satelliten. Und dann kam die Möglichkeit die Cluster zwei Missionen zu führen hier im Esock, die,
als Teamleiterin seit jetzt fast sechs Jahren mache ich das mit Costa.
Mir die Gelegenheit gleich mal wieder auf ein paar alte Sendungen äh zu verweisen in Raumzeit sechsundvierzig habe ich mit Jörg Fischer äh gesprochen über Venus äh.
Haben wir zusammengearbeitet.
Habt ihr zusammen, okay? Und äh auch der Solar-Orbiter war natürlich hier schon ein äh Thema. Da haben wir, damals habe ich mit äh Paulo Ferdi gesprochen. Kurz bevor er die Leitung des ganzen Bereichs übernommen hat,
Ja, das heißt jetzt bist du hier als was war nochmal die offizielle Bezeichnung, Spacecraft, Operationsmanager, das geht ja schon relativ nah an Astronaut ran, oder?
Den zweitausendneun gab's die, diesen äh Astronauten ähm Auswahl.
Mhm.
Und da war ich mit dabei, habe ich mich beworben, tatsächlich. So,
die Möglichkeit gab's schon und ich war ziemlich äh weit. Sie haben sich fast zehntausend Leute beworben,
Von diese zehntausend haben sie eintausend äh zu die erste Runde genommen, da war ich mit dabei,
Da waren wir in äh das Zentrum in Köln, in der in nicht Köln, in Hamburg.
Da wo sie.
Pilotentesten machen, haben sie auch die die erste Runde für Astronauten über und da waren wir äh war ich ein am Tag mit vierzig andere Leute aus ganz in Europa,
nur den ganzen Tag vor dem Computer Test zu machen und mit äh Interviews und so,
und dann tatsächlich bin ich zur nächste Runde gegangen, da waren nur zweihundert und dann, was war schon in Köln beim Astronaut-Zentrum mit ähm mit äh,
psychologischen Testen und viele viele Interviews und Tests und Gruppenarbeiten und so. Und dann bin ich nicht weitergekommen. Aber dann waren so vierzig dann ausgewählt und von diesen die die heutige,
Astronaut äh Hauptteam gewählt, die ich glaube R acht sind sie jetzt ungefähr,
aber die Chance war da. Also ich könnte es schon meinem Vater sagen, ja du es ist falsch.
Okay. Ja, die Prozedur ist mir wohl äh bekannt. Gib mir gleich die Gelegenheit, nochmal auf eine Sendung zu äh verweisen. Raumzeit elf, Astronauten, Ausbildung war das Thema und da habe ich dann halt äh mit der Person gesprochen, die dich rausgeschmissen hat, nämlich Samantha.
Christopher Retti. Ja, die äh das auf jeden Fall verdient hat, da durchzukommen.
Richtig, ja.
Okay, aber bis jetzt nicht unglücklich als äh.
Nee, das ist das zweite nächste zweite beste äh Möglichkeit. Da unten dann fliegt man tatsächlich äh äh ein Schiff in Weltraum, aber man muss nicht weg von seiner Familie bleiben. Man kann.
Ja, das ist eigentlich top. Die wahren Ast.
Beste von beiden Welten.
Ja Fern äh Fernarbeit ist ja sozusagen voll im Trend und,
Von daher ist das ja im Prinzip so, dass dass die die Heimarbeit des Astronauten,
Ähm ja, das ist eigentlich auch nochmal ein ganz gutes ähm Thema, bevor wir dann äh so auf unser Kernthema gehen,
also wir sprechen heute Anfang September zwanzig zwanzig und natürlich hat's auch in Darmstadt den Lokdown gegeben. Ich hab das so ein bisschen
Augenwinkel beobachtet, wie das hier organisiert wurde, also was ja im Prinzip auch alle zu Hause, nur jetzt ist natürlich nicht so, dass man mal soeben seine Arbeit,
zwei Wochen lang sein lassen kann, weil dann fallen ja die ganzen Satelliten vom Himmel
Wie hat das funktioniert? Wie habt ihr euch da äh organisiert
kommen in der kurzen Zeit, wie ist das äh gelaufen, wie macht man das auch so Sicherheits äh technisch, weil normalerweise ist hier so ein
ja so ein äh Bereich, wo man äh allerlei Checks und Controls äh durchgehen muss, alles eingezäunt und einmal sitzen auf einmal alle zu Hause und steuern die Satelliten, wie läuft das.
Es es muss ja, wir müssen uns dafür vorbereiten,
Wir haben das beobachtet, ganz genau, wie wie die Situation sich entwickelt hat. Man das ist ähm.
Ja man man muss hier bei uns schon die Risiken sich gut,
im Augen halten und das haben wir gemacht und wir haben die ersten Maßnahmen jetzt genommen und Teams zu isolieren und Leute allein zu arbeiten lassen im Kontrollraum, das das wenige Risiko.
Aber dann haben wir auch ähm gab's einen Fall von Infektion, schon am Anfang. Jemand war Skifahren von unserer Vögel, Flugdynamik-Team,
und hat tatsächlich geholt und wir dachten, okay, wenn das irgendwann sich verbreitet, dann müssen wir sowieso alles stoppen und dann haben wir,
Vorsichtshalber,
schon ähm mindestens die die wissenschaftlichen ähm Daten haben wir aufgehört zu sammeln. Haben gesagt, okay, wir machen jetzt wenige. Unsere Satelliten, diese Plastikmission.
Man kann sie einfach lassen, die man muss nicht jeden Tag was tun. Die fliegen im Umlaufbahn und das wird nicht gestört,
wir können in so einer so eine Modus bringen, wo sie einfach dastehen. Was haben wir gemacht und äh und dann mussten wir nur im Prinzip einmal in der Woche.
Zugucken, das alles noch in Ordnung war, dass dass die unsere ähm,
dass wir nichts zu tun hatten mit den Salit und dann und dann ist es so für vier Wochen ungefähr so geblieben. Wir haben keine wissensschaftlichen Daten gesammelt, haben wir nur so zugeguckt,
wir haben nur gemessen wo sie sind, dass wir immer wissen ähm genau wo sie sind, falls,
eine Möglichkeit gibt, dass es irgend andere Objekt auf dem Weg steht und und äh dann,
hatten wir Zeit um uns zu organisieren und zu gucken, wie wir das wieder im Vollgang bringen könnten. Mittlerweile.
Und beim Tee und beim TLR haben die Wissenschaftler äh alle geheult wahrscheinlich, ja.
Ja, aber ein bisschen über Harry noch Robbe, aber die haben, die waren sehr, die haben das ganz gut verstanden, um das alle haben uns sehr gut unterstützt,
und das ging wirklich super. Ähm mittlerweile waren wir alle zu Hause ähm und dann haben unsere ganz IT-Team ganz schnell eine eine Secure Network von eine Vibien hergestellt,
und auch dazu spezielle Virtualmaschinens wo man dann,
eine Zugang zu unseren Systemen härter, um die Mission weiter zu planen zu können.
Das war uns wichtig, dass wir mindestens neue Planplanen für die Satelliten herstellen können. Als das geschafft war und wir hatten äh wir waren sicher, dass es eine Gürtellosungphase stabil und unsicher,
dann können wir uns schon wieder vorstellen, dass wir diese Satellinen voll in Arbeit bringen könnten und haben wir dann neue Planungen gemacht und dann,
dann haben wir unsere Kontrollteam in eine isolierte Raum gebracht, nur ein ein Controller,
äh hier an jeder Zeit an wesig und dann haben wir's wieder durchgeführt.
Und seit April läuft das ganz normal wie immer.
Hast du äh hast du eine Zahl im Kopf? Wie viele Objekte ihr gerade von diesem Ort aussteuert? Ja.
Von hier zweiundzwanzig zweiundzwanzig. Mhm.
Zweiundzwanzig. Also nicht zweiundzwanzig Missionen, sondern zweiundzwanzig.
Fünfzehn Missionen, zweiundzwanzig Objekten.
Okay, dass du das jetzt eine etwas präzisere Antwort, als ich sie erwartet hätte, aber okay, das muss man wahrscheinlich im Kopf haben.
Hat mir jemand vor kurzem gefragt, ich hab's gehört. Ich wusste, dass ich das gucke.
Okay, aber das ist ja eine eine Menge Holz und ich meine, wir hatten ja hier schon eine ganze Menge äh Gespräche bei Raumzeit, so über Missionsanalyse und was so getan werden muss. Das macht man sich ja, glaube ich, auch meistens nicht klar. Die meisten Leute sehen halt dann so den Start und dann ist es halt oben und dann
was was soll man da noch machen?
Nee, aber dann fängt die Arbeit ja eigentlich erst an und man muss halt permanent hier Flugbahnen kontrollieren und vor allem eben, wie du schon gesagt hast, die wissenschaftlichen Daten einsammeln
et cetera und alles die ganze Zeit in irgendeiner Form auch auf Anomalin und und irgendwelche Andeutung
überprüfen, ob da vielleicht irgendwas aus dem Ruder äh läuft, weil man muss es ja dann auch früh genug erkennen,
Also so ein permanenter Blick auf die Daten. Das heißt, das hat dann, wenn ich's richtig verstehe, eigentlich ganz gut funktioniert, weil in dem Moment, wo man den Zugang hier zu dem äh Netz hatte, konnte man im Prinzip auch zu Hause arbei.
War das dann eher entspannt oder eher anstrengend.
Am Anfang ist sehr anstrengend, weil ich hab's noch nicht erzählt, aber ich bin äh auch Vater dazu. Ich habe drei, drei Kleinkinder, sieben, neun und elf.
Mhm. Okay. Alles klar.
Musste man Home Schuling auch dazu ähm organisieren und in Gang bringen.
Für die Kinder war das super, die waren entspannter, die konnten ein bisschen länger schlafen, haben gut gegessen, es gab keinen Stress, dass sie dann irgendwann bleiben mussten und dann nur später abgeholt werden. Das das für die Kinder war das ein ein schöner Zeit,
was viel kochen, viel Hausaufgaben, mitmachen, viel Konferenzen dazu und mit Kinder, die man schon gesehen hat, die hin und her vorbeilaufen und.
Kinder seid mal ruhig, ich muss hier kurz einen Satellitenform abstürzen, bewahren.
Ich kann mich an der Zeit ähm äh ganz gut erinnern an Spülmaschinen, Räumen und Ausräumen und es war die ganze Zeit so.
Gut, von diesen äh fünfzehn Missionen, äh die ihr hier derzeit am Laufen habt, ist eine davon heißt Cluster oder Cluster zwei. Ist das jetzt die zweite Phase oder was.
Nee, es gab Plaster eins, aber es hat äh vierzig Sekunden gedauert die Mission. Es war die das das erste Flug von Arian fünf.
Also ein Testflug und äh es war umsonst, deshalb haben sie das äh das zwei äh neu sechsundneunzig.
Zweitausend. Zweitausendneunzehn neunzig. Sechsundneunz.
In sechsundneunzig, erste Flugarean fünf und Hartz fünf, vierzig Sekunden gedauert und hat äh die Rakete hat aus dem Flugmann äh.
Gegangen und dann mussten die tatsächlich die Mission enden an dem Punkt und ist explodiert und da war's zu Ende,
Aber als sie diese erste Plastikmission gebaut haben, haben sie tatsächlich fünf Objekten gebaut, vier zum Fliegen und eins als Modell, um um Testen zu machen am Boden,
Aber der war auch der fünfte war auch flugbereit. Da konnte man in Prinzip benutzen,
Und dann haben sich Esel damals entschieden, okay, wir bauen.
Drei dazu, machen's wieder, weil was was diese Mission dann studiert, wie, wie sich diese Sonnen sind in unserem Magnetenfeld ähm,
wir das beeinflusst. Da braucht man schon,
diese vier Punkten, um diese drei Dimensionen zu diese Phänomen zu zu beobachten. In Zeit und in Raum. Da braucht man dann.
Ist quasi so eine dreidimensionale oder vierdimensionale Beobachtung des Einflusses, des Sonnenwinds aufs Erdmagnetf.
Ja, wir messen das Institut, das das ist keine Mission, was eine Kamera benutzt, um Sachen entfernt zu gucken, sondern das messt, was passiert auf der Punkt, wo wir fliegen. Und wir fliegen ganz hoch,
Wir gehen weit äh außer der Magnetenfilterer, dass das so über sechzigtausend Kilometer entfernt. Da gehen wir und gucken wie diese diese Sonnen sind,
ganz sauber kommt von von der Sonne und dann gehen wir rein und sehen, wie das in die verschiedenen Schichten unser Magnetenfeld dann wie das dann äh.
Neue Phänomene entsteht, wie wie die Plasma sich.
Das heißt ihr stürzt euch sozusagen richtig auf so einen Sonnenwindeffekt dynamisch drauf. Also man beobachtet, sieht da passiert was und dann schaut man sich das bewusst an. Es ist nicht so eine permanente Beobachtung und da passiert mal was.
Ja, das ist Assistant Brief, wie wir messen das seit zwanzig Jahren und in dieser Zeit hat sich die Sonne mehrmals in seinen Zyklus äh geändert, so einmal war er sehr aktiv und dann wieder.
Wenig aktiv und dann hoch und dann das ändert sich wie wie oft man eine eine Corono Masse Jacktion kriegt wie diese.
Dieser Sturm aus der Wind, aus der Sonne kommen,
Und da hat man alles so schon alle diesen Perioden verschiedenen Phänomene beobachtet und wie dann das alles auf die Erde, wie unser Magnet fällt, sich so dynamisch bewegt, wie wir das unterdrückt,
wird und wie diese Partikeln, diese Teilchen dann in die auf die Erde zuschlagen, von den Polen oder oder durch andere Mechanismus ähm,
wir sammeln im Prinzip so viel Daten wie möglich, um das,
dann später zu modellieren, um um um auch zu vorhersagen, wie das dann entwickelt, wenn wenn der neue Sturm kommt, was wären dann die Konsequenzen? Nicht nur für die Erde, aber auch für andere Satelliten, die die Open fliegen.
Genau, weil es ein richtiges Problem im Prinzip oder ein potenzielles Problem zumindest so. Das potentielle Problem. Mh.
Es kann zu potentiellen Problemen äh durchführen für in auf die Erde, für elektrische Netzwerke, für für Computers, für ähm ja für Kommunikation.
Für Podcasts. Internet, schön hatte.
Ich hatte das äh äh Thema vor kurzem hier in Raumzeit äh fünfundachtzig habe ich mich mit Volker äh Botmar äh unterhalten,
und äh da vom Institut für Astrophysik in Göttingen das mehr so die die Seite sozusagen auf der äh Sonne, die wir dort äh beleuchtet haben. Die Clustermission ist dann sozusagen ein Teil der
Beobachtung der Sonne quasi auf der Erde. Okay ähm.
Wir gehören beide zu Heliophysik. So wir verstehen ein bisschen was was die Sonne macht und wir gehören auch zu Geophysik. So, was passiert auf der Erde? Jetzt in zweitausendneunzehn hat die Klasse Mission tatsächlich einen Preis,
von der Royal äh Stronomical Society in äh England bekommen fürs Geophysik. Und äh ja, für unsere.
Für eure kontinuierliche Arbeit sozusagen. Ja, gut, dass es dann nicht runtergefallen ist in der Corona-Zeit.
Nee, nee,
aber es wird runterkommen. Es in zweitausend ab zwei äh vierundzwanzig kommt die der erste Satellit runter,
Das kann man nicht mehr ändern. Unser Umlaufbahn ist so hoch, dass es wird von Sonne und Mond äh gestört,
und hat so eine eigene Dynamik. Es ist nicht überzeitstabil, aber das das tanzt ein bisschen, geht hoch und runter. Und jetzt kommt es runter.
Und dann ist der Treibstoff alle.
Treibstoff ist schon fast alle. Wir haben äh vier bis sechs Kilo in jeder Satellit, weißt du, wir hatten sechshundert am Anfang. Und jetzt ist es genug, im Moment zum zum neuen Formationen zu fliegen und neue Arbeit ist nicht genug, um zu verhindern, dass wir,
abstürzen und dann vierundzwanzig kommt eine, fünfundzwanzig, die zweite und sechsundzwanzig kommen die letzten zwei runter und dann verbrennen sich in die Atmosphäre und das war's.
Bis dann, wir hoffen, wir können das weiter betreiben. Die sind.
Wie ist denn das so, wenn man wenn man so eine Mission so lange begleitet hat? Also weiß ja jetzt wahrscheinlich noch nicht, wenn's dann mal zu Ende ist so. Weißt du schon, was das nächste ist oder entscheidet sich, dass.
Ähm habe schon eine Idee, wir wir machen im Moment so eine äh es kommen zwei neue Missionen zu unserer Abteilung, äh Hera, das ist eine erste Rogid-Mission,
und Ero, das ist die europäische Return Orbiter, das ist eine Satellit, der zu Maß fliegt und bringt,
von Maßumlaufbahn eine.
Probe. Probe. Mhm.
Eine Probe was was vom vom Boden hochkommt und wird dann wieder zur Erde gebracht. So, das ist eine Mission zusammen mit mit Nase, die die Amerikaner machen äh den Rufe und und sammeln diese,
Diese Proben und dann schicken eine Rakete hoch und wir treffen uns mit diesen mit diesen Orbitter.
Und bringe diese Probe zurück zur Erde. So, diese zwei neue Missionen kommen und wir müssen dann unsere Abteilung ein bisschen.
Ändern, dass dass mit unsere Leute alle in so ist es. Ich hoffe ab Januar wird das ein bisschen ändern und dann habe ich auch vielleicht ein anderes Projekt in der Hand.
Entspannt. So, jetzt wollen wir dann nochmal auf das eigentliche Thema äh schreiten. Wann bist du denn.
Da muss er irgendwann mal zu viel Zeit gehabt haben. Ähm also vielleicht sollte man es kurz nochmal sagen, Curble Space Programm ist eine,
Simulation, an physikalische Simulation,
wenn ich das richtig sehe primär die Erde und ihre Umgebung, es ist keine interstellare, wir fliegen in andere Galaxien äh Simulationen, das kommt dann vielleicht in der Zukunft noch,
und ist äh auf der einen Seite äh ja ganz verspielt. Es gibt da kleine grüne Männchen, die äh dort eine gewisse Rolle spielen,
ähm aber vor allem ist es halt eine Umgebung, in der man im Prinzip seine eigene Raumfahrt betreiben kann.
Wie bist du da drauf gekommen? Was kannst du davon erinnern, wie.
Ganz genau, kann ich nicht. Es war zufällig,
jemand in unserer Abteilung hat, das hat das gefunden und hat den Link geschickt. Das war damals nur eine Beta-Version. Das war so eine Firma, hat das als Spaß gebaut. Die ich glaube, diese diese Firma Private Division ähm.
Die hat ein irgendein anderes Ziel und das war so ein Nebenprojekt von von jemand in dieser Firma und er hat das ah ich will so ein Spiel bauen über Weltraum. Und er hat dieses Spiel gewonnen, der war schon sehr schön, das war Beta und der hat.
Die wollten so Leute, die das testen würden. Und da haben wir es runtergeladen, ich und andere Kollegin,
haben, damit sie so ein bisschen angefangen, was kann man damit machen, ja, hier ein Raket äh starten,
und und auf einmal waren wir ein bisschen so süchtig, ne nach dem Spiel und es ging immer. So, das ist ein kleines Sonnensystem, das ist ein bisschen kleiner als unsere,
um auch das ist alles ein bisschen schneller geht, dass man schneller Umlauf um diese Planet geht. Also das war schon lustig und und das Lustige daran war, dass man,
ich habe seit meinem Studium viel über dieser Weltraum Mechanik gelernt. Ich habe die die Equations gelernt und ich ich weiß theoretisch, wie das alles läuft, aber eben praktisch.
Das ist dann diese Erfahrung, was die die ersten Astronauten auch gehabt haben,
wenn wenn du diese neue Films guckst von Napolo Elf über äh Armstrong und die erste Mal, als sie versucht haben im Weltraum ein ein Honda und Doking zu machen. Das war nicht logisch, wie wie man dann fliegt,
wo man diese Raketen, wie diese ähm Triebwerke dann in welche Richtung muss man das das richtig ähm,
Freuen, man weiß, dass von der Mathematik, aber von von Fliegen, von Steuern, von von das Gefühl,
Das war ganz neu und das endet in in unsere Kopf, wie man dann an Weltweltraum fliegend denkt,
Wanders kann viel grafischer, viel mehr lebendig,
im Kopf haben. Und das das macht es, das gibt's ein lustiges äh Cartoon im Internet, es geht meine Verständnis über Weltraumfliegen und das ist so eine Grafik,
Und das geht so leicht hoch, also man in die ins Gymnasium kommt und ein bisschen Oberphysik lernt und dann geht's ein bisschen höher, wenn man Generie studiert und dann ein bisschen höher, wenn man zuerst er kommt und dann endlich, wenn man Kirball spielt.
Geht das so.
Dann versteht man das erst.
Man endlich. Ah, da rüber ging.
Und das war so diese dieser Effekt. Und äh mittlerweile äh ja haben wir alles schon da probiert, Rande Wus und äh große Raumstationen zu bauen und zu anderen Planeten fliegen und zurückkommen,
und das eine Zeit lang, die ersten Jahren haben wir wirklich,
Zeit investiert, aber dann ab dem zweiten Kind ging das der Zeit,
war gering und dann,
wenige. Aber aber trotzdem äh immer wenn ich bei uns Praktikanten habe, dann benutze ich den Spiel, um um um richtige Sachen zu erklären.
Aber erklären wir doch erstmal so ein bisschen, wie diese Software äh was eigentlich so der Ansatz ähm ist. Also das läuft ja auf allen möglichen Plattformen mittlerweile, al
äh ist ja dann sehr erfolgreich äh geworden und ähm ja, der Zugang dazu ist äh quasi eigentlich auf jedem Rechner möglich. Was
was bildet denn Curble als erstes erstmal? Also woraus besteht quasi dieses kleine Universum.
Okay, erst bist du in deiner, in deine Raumvateragentur und hast die Möglichkeiten,
Raketen zu bauen oder irgendwas, was du kommst in diese Halle und in dieser Halle ist es leer und da hast du an deiner linken Seite eine Menü mit alle Sorten teilen von Antrieb,
und Tanks mit verschiedenen Sorten von Treibstoff, entweder monopropellend oder pipropellend oder irgendwelche,
da hast du viel Auswahl. Und mit verschiedene Großen, Riesentanks, kleine Tanks, mit äh Solidoosters, mit,
Mit Kapseln für eins oder zwei oder drei Astronauten mit äh Fallschirm, mit mit Beinen, mit Flügeln. Alles Mögliche ist da und du hast Freiwahl. Du kannst jetzt.
Was du willst. Da sei es kein Ziel im Prinzip. Du kannst auch, es gibt einen Modus, wo man sein Ziel bekommt, aber ich spiele gerne ohne Ziel,
und man denkt, ich heute, was will ich heute machen? Heute will ich zum ähm zum äh Duner. Dunest ist die,
so ähnlich wie unser Maß. Der der erste Planeten nach außen. Auch rot mit äh mit weißen Karten. Sieht sehr ähnlich wie unser Maß, aber heißt Dune in dem Spiel. Nennt sich will nach Duneck gehen.
Und dann fangst dann zu bauen. Äh wie viele Leute bringe ich? Was brauche ich dafür? Okay, muss von von,
von von Ende zu Prinzip bauen. Du musst denken, okay, irgendwann komme ich zurück zu Erden, da muss ich landen. Dann das Erste ist eine Kapsel mit Fallschirm,
Aber bevor ich lande, muss ich von Dune nach Erde fliegen. Da brauche ich mindestens so viel Treibstoff. Einen kleinen Tank, Triebwerk, das würde reichen, diese,
und dann,
bin ich am Boden von Du und er muss sich von Boden nach oben. Wie viel brauche ich dafür? Und wie mache ich, wann trenne ich meine meine Raumschiff,
Wann immer ist es sinnvoll, dann äh kleiner zu machen und dann gehst du immer zurück, bist du ganz Anfang und dann hast du so ein riesen Dings, was du auf dem,
Staat äh Rampe bringst und dann,
ändert sich, das war die Bauphase, äh bist du fertig damit und dann jetzt kommt die die Steuernphase.
Bleiben wir nochmal bei der Bauphase. Also das ist jetzt im Prinzip so ein riesiger Werkzeugkasten, der so alles äh zur Verfügung stellt, was bisher so die Raumfahrttechnik hatte und vielleicht noch ein paar Sachen, die die Raumfahrttechnik noch nicht äh hatte, nehme ich mal an. Also gibt's, gibt's da jetzt auch irgendwelch.
Verrückte Sachen, so Nuklear Angins, es war gibt's auch so, aber man kann sich vorstellen, vielleicht gibt es heutzutage noch nicht die Technik, was die da,
bevorschlagen, aber total Unsinn ist es nicht,
ist Missmacht, ist es schon an der Physik gegründet irgendwie. Manchmal ein bisschen übertrieben, aber schon richtig.
Und muss man sich auch denken von äh man man braucht äh nicht nur ähm,
treiben, sondern Aue auch Strom äh Schutz vor Hitze. Ähm man muss sich um die Mechanik kümmern, dass dass die Teile nicht auseinanderbrechen im Flug mit mit der Trug,
muss man nicht nur um das Fliegen denken aber auch um das ganze System. Das macht es zu einer,
zu einer Systementwicklung Problem.
Weil man halt sich irgendwas zusammenbauen kann, was man erstmal zusammenstecken und starten kann, aber dann kann's ein wie zehn Minuten später gleich um die Ohren fliegen, weil man halt irgendwie.
Falsch gebaut.
Gebaut hat, irgendwelche Hitzeverteilungen, nicht berücksichtigt hat oder.
Wenn damit man damit anfangt, sofort nach fünf Sekunden ist es schon explodiert, dann muss man wieder zurück, was ändern, neues, bisschen stärker hier, ein bisschen äh leichter da und.
Weißt du denn, was der Hintergrund der ursprünglichen Entwickler äh war, wo die dieses Wissen hergenommen haben oder war das erstmal komplett spielerisch und hat sich erst später in so ein wissenschaftliches Werkzeug verwandelt.
Ähm ich weiß es nicht genau. Ähm Anfang war's, was war so ein Nebenprojekt, ein Spiel.
Und er hat sich da mittlerweile sehr sehr stark entwickelt. Es es gab von Anfang an schon eine große ähm,
Community. Es gab schon ja viele, viele äh Leute, die dann äh das super fanden und haben äh auch äh Feedback gegeben, äh dass das hier funktioniert nicht so gut, das wäre besser so und,
das Spiel war auch offen. So, man könnte seine eigene Teile separat entwickeln, so neue Kapseln, neue Triebwerke und in den Spiel bringen,
Und das hat auch gebracht, dass viele dann das auch lustig fanden und haben eine noch stärker Community gebaut mit mit äh Austausch von Teilen und.
Das heißt, man muss nicht nur mit dem arbeiten, was da ist, sondern es gibt so ladbare Module, alles Mögliche. Jeder, der irgendwas baut, kann das allen dann zur Verfügung stellen.
Leute, die ja, die wollen ein haben, dann haben sie diese diese schöne äh Triebwerke von,
gezeichnet und gebaut und programmiert und dann in den Spiel gebracht und dann das haben die dann frei für alle gemacht,
und gab's dann viel Tutorials, viele Videos, gibt's äh in mittlerweile professionelle Videos über Körbel im im YouTube,
ist sogar so so ein Star von von Körbel, wenn man das Google, der hat so Millionen vorgesehene Schotte,
der in der USA lebt und äh der macht super Videos und erklärt die Physik dahinten, was möglich ist, was nicht. Der der macht immer so verrückte Sachen, Sachen und spielt in echte Zeit unerklärt,
wie er das macht, warum so. Man kann viel mit diesen Videos lernen. Äh und wie haben wir auch.
Ja. So ein bisschen wie man das auch von Mindcraft äh kannte, ne.
Richtig. So eine ähnliche.
So ein bisschen, dass dass das mit Mindcraft für Space so, ne? Mhm.
Na ja, ich wollte nochmal so ein bisschen rausfinden, was man in dieser Bauphase alles so äh bedenken kann. Also wenn man vielleicht jetzt einfach mal versuchen, so eine Mission, so eine Selb
ausgedachte Mission, vielleicht bleiben wir einfach mal bei deinem äh Duden Wüsten äh äh Planet sozusagen. Also
Das ist jetzt quasi nicht unser Sonnensystem, sondern es sind andere Planeten, die jetzt äh in in Körbe vorhanden sind,
OK ähm so du hast ja gesagt OK jetzt brauchen wir erstmal 'ne Kapsel für die Astronauten. Die Astronauten sind die Kurbels. Ja, das sind diese kleinen grünen äh.
Planet heißt Kurbin. Äh die Sonne heißt Care Bowl.
Und die Wesen heißen Köbels und die haben alle tolle Namen, so und Valentina Kermen und Bill Kermen und die sind ja, die sind immer dabei so ein bisschen immer fröhlich.
Oder ihr ähm und ja, machen alles mit. So.
Egal, die die nehmen alle Risiko an und äh ja, muss man denken, ja, wir bringen ihn zu dieser Planeten, was,
Was wollen sie da machen? Spazierengehen, wenn vielleicht braucht man einen Rowe, was man bringt zum zum Fahren,
oder so 'ne Modul wo Sie leben können mit Solarpanelen und da muss man muss man sich dann.
Gedanken machen, was wir immer machen. Wie kommen die denn zurück? Ähm.
Aber wie kann man jetzt, kann man sich hier so einen Dom einfach selber bauen oder muss es den mehr oder weniger als vorgefertigtes Modul schon äh geben.
Es gibt so kleine Module, sie ist schon fast fertig sind, aber man muss schon paar Sachen zusammenstecken, bis man so ein, so ein äh funktionierendes äh.
So ein bisschen so Space Lego.
Kann man so sagen. Sie sind Legoteile. Man steckt sie zusammen.
Steckt die zusammen und dann hat das irgendwie auch eine Funktion.
Die sehen gut aus, sie sehen echt aus, so plausibel, das alles und man man muss auch ähm,
Dinge. Vielleicht gibt's in diesem Planet so eine Atmosphäre, dann kann man dann äh mit mit äh Jets fliegen dort, wenn wenn da äh Sauerstoff gibt, dann dann funktioniert auch ein Jet, da kann man sparen,
kann man alle Trade offs machen, was man was man braucht.
Wie viel Planeten gibt's denn.
Also es gibt fast ähnlich wie unsere Sonnensystem bis Jupiter,
noch eins dazu. So so es gibt so eine ähnlich wie Mercur, wie Venus, Erde, Merkmaß und dann Jupiter und dann noch ein kleiner Panetz, die der.
So 'ne ähnliche Umlaufbahn hat wie Pluto ungefähr so weit weg und dann gibt's Asteroiden auch.
Gibt's alle diese Planeten haben auch Mohnen.
Unsere die die Hauptplanette Kerbin, die Erde hat zwei Monde, sogar Muhn und Mimnus. Und Mimus ist ein bisschen weiter entfernt, ganz klein mit ganz weniger äh Schwerkraft.
Und ja, kann man die besuchen.
Und haben dir dann auch ähnliche Eigenschaften wie die Planeten der Erde, äh das äh des Sonnensystems ähm oder.
Ja, ja, manche sind weit, ganz weiß, voller Eis, manche sind so nur ein Stein, manche haben Ozeanen, so die sind sehr unterschiedlich. Atmosphäre. Atmosphären.
Ja, aber auch Atmosphären. Atmosphäre. Also sind sie nicht so wie unsere Planeten? Weil ich meine, so richtige Atmosphäre haben wir ja eigentlich nur auf der Erde.
Wir haben noch Venus, eine riesen Atmosphäre und auf Maß haben wir in ganz dünner Atmosphäre, aber immer noch. Es gibt, es gibt Winde und.
Pluto halt auch sowas ähnliches.
Und auf Titan haben wir Atmosphäre und wir haben viele Atmosphäre näher für unsere.
Die Planeten haben dann auch alle viele Monde und so, also es gibt schon so einige Objekte, wo man hinfahren kann und äh man muss nicht so viel Zeit investieren, das ist schon mal ganz praktisch. Okay. Und Juden ist einer davon.
Ja du eine hast. Äh ja, sehr schön. Bewussten Planet.
Der Wüstenplanet. Na ja ok.
Rot aus für unsere Maß.
Okay, also es hat auch diese typische Science-Fiction äh Integration sozusagen noch mit dabei.
Und dann kann man fliegen, dann kommt das Fliegerei.
Moin, müssen,
wir wollen nochmal bauen. Also wir fliegen nach Duden. Ähm so jetzt äh braucht man ich, ich fand diese Idee ganz gut, dass man quasi so das das Bauen eines,
Spacecraft quasi rückwärts denken muss,
so und äh das heißt man will erstmal zurückkehren und man will mit mit äh Astronauten, also mit Körbitz zurück äh kehren. Also braucht man erstmal eine Kapsel, wo genau die Anzahl von,
reinpasst, muss man dann,
da muss man sich ja dann quasi auch noch über deren Versorgung Gedanken machen, also muss ja irgendwie genug Sauerstoff zum Atem, also atmen die, genauso wie wir, also sind sie so mehr so wie Menschen oder haben die irgendwie so ein anderes Mannhaar, mit dem die überleben.
Ähm die Lebens äh Qualität von von Körbels ist schlecht.
Man muss sich nicht so viele Gedanken machen, die müssen nicht viel essen, muss man sich nicht kümmern. Sauerstoff im Prinzip ist da genug. Solange sie im im in ihrem Modul bleiben, in ihre Kapseln bleiben, ist es.
Kein Thema, muss man sich in den Spielen nicht nicht darum kümmern. Ähm nur, dass es Strom gibt und und dass die ja, das ist.
Ja Hauptsache.
Nichts.
Ne
Vielleicht in die, in die nächste Version kommt auch, weil jede Version kommt ein neues,
die die am Anfang waren die Atmosphäre da und aber man könnte raus und rein kommen und es äh und ja hat ein bisschen,
Es hat äh so schön ausgesehen, mit mit dem Plasma, wenn man rein in die Atmosphäre, aber es hat keiner Effekt.
Hitze, aber dann kam eine neue Version und dann kam Hitze dazu. Da musste man sich schon denken, okay, jetzt mache ich ein, ein, ein Schild vor meine,
die haben's immer weiter einen neues Element in den Spiel gebracht, was man am Anfang wussten wir auch um Strom nicht kümmern. Man muss einfach.
Losfliegen. Ähm mittlerweile haben sie, okay, Moment mal. Ohne Strom geht das nicht. Man kann keine äh Raumschippsteuern, wenn wenn.
Das heißt, so langsam sichert quasi so diese echte Space Engineering Realität äh äh.
Und das haben sie super ähm in den Spiel gebracht und ähm nachhaltig, weil,
immer wenn ein neues Modell kommt, dann kommt das Spiel im Prinzip langsam auf. Also es muss noch mehr Sachen rechnen in echte Zeit. Und das haben sie immer angepasst, dass die Performance nicht beschädigt wurde von neuen Modellen.
Also sie gehen quasi mit dem Performance-Gewinn der Rechner und Grafikkarten. Mhm.
Und das hat und das damit haben sie keine Spiele verloren, weil die Leute haben nicht, oh jetzt, das geht nicht mehr, ich habe keinen Bock, weil es ist zu langsam. Das das kam immer,
Performance und und neue Features zusammen. Ähm, haben die das gemacht? Und deshalb ist es noch sehr erfolgreich, den Spiel. Es läuft wunderbar,
mit super Graphics. Man kann ihn mittlerweile auf die Erde sieht man viel mehr Details wie wie das Wasser aussieht von oben, die die Wolken und das das,
Man hat immer gemerkt, dass es immer besser geworden ist und äh.
Ja, das liegt wahrscheinlich auch da dran, dass es wahrscheinlich bei allen äh Raumfahrtstandorten der Welt äh besonders viel und besonders schnell Freunde gefunden hat. Da bist du ja wahrscheinlich das beste Beispiel dafür, dass wenn irgendwie also ich habe so ein bisschen so den Eindruck, am Anfang war es so,
Okay, wir tun mal so ein bisschen wie Weltraumfahrt so, ja und äh
bring so ein paar spielerisch spielerische Elemente rein, haben aber irgendwie so den Ton getroffen, dass es eben dann auch die äh Profis und Leute, die so ein bisschen mehr Einblick haben, so interessiert, ja, man könnte ja das noch machen, könnte das noch machen
entwickelt sich das sozusagen langsam zu so einer richtigen Simulation.
Diese dieses Spiel hat eine Magie, weil die haben's auch von Anfang an, die diese Planeten von oben,
Die sehen sehr, sehr realistisch aus,
Und das hat immer diese Gefühle gebracht, also man so neue Planet ankam und langsam kommt das näher und näher und man sieht die Details. Also sie kommen, das hat eine eine Magie. Man hat so.
Gänsehaut bekommen, als man in diese in diese äh.
Lange äh Fahrt durch den Sonnensystem gemacht hat und dann endlich kommt man zu diesem Ziel und dann man überfliegt das und guckt von oben und sucht sich, wo würde ich jetzt landen,
Suche mir eine große Karte, wo es hoffentlich einigermaßen flach ist.
Da will ich landen und man plant sich und man ist oben und sieht von unten, es ist ein bisschen. Äh ich kann nicht sagen, das ist wie Armstrong. Natürlich ist es nicht,
Aber hat schon eine für, ich finde auch für junge Leute und Leute, die das nie erfahren haben, hatten ein bisschen Magie, wenn man ans Ziel kommt und.
Ja viel scheitert bevor man sozusagen dahin,
Ähm will nochmal versuchen so ein bisschen Chronologie reinzubringen. Also wenn man jetzt wir wollen jetzt zu June äh fliegen, so jetzt
da haben wir also äh quasi, man baut sich halt eine Rakete zusammen so und das ist ja im Prinzip genauso wie es auch im in der richtigen Raumfahrt ist
man braucht eben diese ganzen Elemente, man muss sie zusammenbringen und am Ende muss man sie halt auch noch auf eine Art und Weise zusammenbringen. Das ist eben dann die entsprechenden realen Herausforderungen des Weltraums beziehungsweise vor allem auch erstmal des Staats
auch wirklich überleben kann. Wie kann man das dann,
testen, also gibt's sozusagen auch so ein, so ein Teststand, also wenn man jetzt hier äh was zusammenbaut, dann geht das ja alles erstmal zum Astace nach äh Holland und wird auf Herz und Nieren geprüft, sind diese ganzen Testcenter-Elemente dort auch äh vorhanden.
Man testet im im Fliegen.
Überall.
Im All. Und wenn's nicht klappt, hat man so einen Knopf, man macht Esk und dann zurück zu Halle. Und dann geht man zurück in Zeit,
Und ist zurück in die Halle, kann das wieder da bringen? Neues wird. Es ist ein bisschen so wie Space. Space macht es auch in echt,
Die haben die haben zuerst ein Falk und neun entwickelt, das hochgehen kann. Ohne einen Satellit bringen kann,
Und dann haben sie langsam mit jeder mit jeder Flug diese diese ähm neue Kapazität, die die Raketen wieder zu landen,
haben sie's immer getestet und die ersten fünf, sechs, weiß ich nicht.
Umgekippt und so.
Umgekippt und explodiert und ging's nicht. Und das ist so einer Methode, um um eine,
Rakete zu entwickeln. Okay, das klappt kein Menschen dazu. Das kam viel viel später bei Space Acts, dass die endlich äh Astronauten. Das war jetzt zweitausendzwanzig. Die ersten Astronauten.
Aber okay, im Spiel ist kein echter Leben.
Aber Körper und Space X sind auch in etwa gleich alt.
Ich äh richtig, zweitausendzwölf.
Mhm.
Angefangen. Aber man kann als Entwickler in den Spiel, man kann in äh in paar Stunden das hinkriegen, was Basics in mehreren Jahren gemacht hat,
macht man in dem Spiel in in paar Tagen mit Geduld.
Aber äh genau, aber man braucht diese Geduld und man ist halt so das klassische Trial and Aero, man probiert's halt irgendwie aus und dann sieht man so, okay, alles klar, jetzt bin ich soweit gekommen, aber weiter komme ich jetzt nicht, weil ich habe ja irgendwas Wichtiges.
Ist mit, ist viel, viel Trial Narr. Man kann so Shotguts machen, man guckt Tutorials, man man hat einen Freund, der ist schon erfahren,
damit hat Erfahrung und äh,
da gibt's so einen Shotguts, aber da ist viel Trioler, Trial. Man versucht und dann ist man äh erfolgreich und hat schon die erste Schritt gemacht, aber irgendwann auf dem Weg nach Maß ist es dann doch falsch gegangen und.
Okay, dann lass mal weiter den Flug äh äh nach Dunen äh äh machen. Also wir haben jetzt sozusagen oben die Kapsel zum Bummeln rückkehren. Wir haben den Treibstoff, um zurückzukehren. Wir haben den Treibstoff um auch irgendwie erstmal hinzufliegen,
was brauchen wir noch? Man muss ja irgendwie landen und wie du schon sag,
Spaß haben, also nimmt man halt noch so ein Rover äh mit, weil hat man ja sozusagen heutzutage. Ohne Over ist ja nix.
Da gibt's dann irgendwie, also kann man diese Raketen beliebig groß bauen oder haben die nicht irgendwie, ich meine, gibt's da irgendwelche Beschränkungen.
Die die einige Beschränkungen ist die Physik. Aber ja. Wie wie.
Ja. Aber. Das meinte ich eigentlich auch. Also ich meine, was was sie was beschränkt denn die Physik dann an der Stelle.
Beschränkt, wenn etwas enorm groß ist, es kann sein, dass sofort an dem Moment, dass du in der Startrampe liegst, dann fängt das an zu.
Auseinanderzufallen und.
Auseinander zu fallen und explodiert direkt.
Mhm.
Wenn das, wenn das äh nicht gut kompakt und richtig miteinander gebunden ist, dann dann geht's auch nicht,
sofort. Dann alle Teile äh haben ein Modell, wie sie sich mit anderen Teilen verbinden und ob diese Verbindung stabil und,
und ähm oder ob da irgendwelche Bewegungen und und Anstrengungen gibt. Und wenn's so, dann bricht es zusammen,
Wenn nicht an der Rampe, dann sofort, als man hochgeht und die und diese Luftdruck kommt, dann geht es auseinander. So.
Die Begrenzung erste Physik, aber im Prinzip, wenn man Kreativität hat und und Zeit hat und Geduld, dann kann man,
sich ganz fein etwas riesig bauen.
Okay, dann starten wir doch jetzt mal mit unserer tollen neuen äh äh Rakete. Da sagt man einfach so, jetzt geht's los, Start und dann kriegt man auch sofort einen Slot. Und dann ähm beim Stadt kann ja eine Menge schief gehen.
Ähm ja, ja, mir, ja. Ähm dann wieder zurück. Das.
Also was muss man dann machen? Also muss man dann irgendwie die Treibstoffmenge selber berechnen, muss man die Kühlung berücksichtigen, al.
Mittlerweile äh man hat schon viele viele Hilfe von den Spiel. Wenn du baust da hast du an der rechten Seite das zeigt dir wie schwer du bist und wie viel,
Geschwindigkeit mit diese Rakete du du kriegst, wenn du fliegst und.
Es gibt auch äh so äh Karten. Im Internet kannst du die runterladen und da steht,
dieser Planet, zu dieser Planet, wie viele Geschwindigkeit, wie äh auf unsere Sprache heißt das Delta V,
Wie viele Geschwindigkeit brauchst du, um von einer Pläne zu andere zu gehen? Und das, diese Karten gibt's auch für Körbe, für die, für die,
Planeten in dieses Spiel. Und dann kannst du gucken, okay, ich meine erste Stufe oder äh hat es schon genug, Treibstoff für diese Strecke, was ich machen will? Das kannst du schon,
das wird automatisch berechnet und und wird dir gezeigt und kannst du das in Augen behalten was du schon hast.
Mhm. Mhm.
Und ähm.
Man kann immer neue Antrieb dazu machen, wenn man braucht. Aber bei mir äh was ich schön finde, ist die Simplizität, sind die einfachste Lösung, was ein Ziel erreicht,
Ohne zu viel Schnickschnack, weil Schnickschnack sind immer Risiko äh.
Geht kaputt.
Geht kaputt oder kommt den Weg oder.
Und es ist eben beim mit einem echten äh Satelliten ist es auch so. Man braucht nur so viel, wie man äh braucht. Nicht mehr.
Genau und nicht weniger.
Nicht wenige, weil wenige, dann ist auch ein Risiko da,
man macht immer ein zweites, ein äh Redundanz und so muss man daran denken. Aber im Spiel, ich, ich, ich, ich mache, ich ich finde es schön, die die einfachsten Lösungen.
Gibt's denn dann auch so einen Zufall? Also ich meine, wenn man jetzt sagt, Redundanz, nicht? Dann heißt das ja, okay, ich habe zwar eigentlich das richtige Ding eingebaut, aber manchmal gehen die Sachen halt auch einfach kaputt,
sie nicht richtig gebaut wurden und so weiter. Also gibt's dieses Zufallselement, dass dann Dinge auch einfach mal versagen auch im Spiel?
Ja, mir gibt's viel Zufall, gibt's Sachen, was man nicht wirklich gedacht hatte.
Sonnenwind.
Noch nicht da, aber.
Aber einmal wollte ich zu dieser Planet heißt Eve Yve ist in unserem System, sondern System ist Venus,
auch in diesem Spiel er ist groß, größer als die Erde da, er ist groß und hat eine dicke Atmosphäre.
Eigentlich diese das schwierigste Ziel in diesem Spiel, dieser Planet dort zu landen und wieder hochzukommen. Habe ich noch nicht geschafft. Aber ich habe versucht zu landen. Ich habe so eine so eine Rakete gebracht, sehr groß und ich habe.
Stundenlang versucht dieser Hygid in in Senkrecht.
Auf den Boden zu bringen, hat nicht geklappt. Und dann habe ich immer Teile dazu gebracht von von der Erde. Bis am Ende habe ich so eine so eine,
so eine Art ähm.
So ein paar Flügeln gebaut zusammen, was ich auf die Nase von dieser Hake gesteckt habe, um das mit dem mit der Atmosphäre und mit dieser Luftrück, um das zu,
in dieser Position zu halten, weil sonst er hat immer umgedreht und mit Nase nach unten gegangen.
Egal was ich machte, das hatte immer passiert und dann kam diese habe ich dieses Stück entwickelt, was man auf die Nase stecken könnte,
Da war äh ähm ich habe da einen Doking Port gemacht, am am Anfang, weil sie dachte, irgendwann muss ich diese Mensch zurückbringen und dann werde ich diese diese Kapsel docken und,
Dann in diese Doggenport habe ich diese Nase, diese Nase mit Flugeln gebracht. Und das hat endlich funktioniert,
Und aber da habe ich weiß ich nicht, zehn, zwölf Mal versucht bis,
bis ich zu dieser Idee kam und das aber um diese Teile zu bringen,
habe ich eine neue Mission entwickelt, aus der Erde gestartet mit dieser Teil dann in in Umlaufband von Venus, die andere getroffen, dieser Teil das.
Oh, super. Das ist endlos.
Endlos, Endlos. Es gibt Missionen in Missionen, in Missionen, bis man etwas.
Ist denn also wenn so eine Simulation mit wo man sagt okay dicke Atmosphäre und ohne die Flügel kriege ich das Ding nicht gelandet,
wie, wie richtig,
wie korrekt ist diese Physik, die da zur Anwendung kommt. Ich meine, das weiß man ja jetzt sozusagen nicht wirklich wie so ein anderer Planet, also Venus hat ja auch immer viel Überraschung und das
dort zu landen und so weiter, ist ja auch bisher ja, ist schon mal geglückt, aber halt,
große Herausforderung, ne? Druck, Sturm et cetera und ähm.
Wie wie wissenschaftlich ist, sind sind diese physikalischen Simulationen, die in in Kerbal sind.
Ja, sehr realistisch. So alles äh von von.
Hitzetauschen, von Erodynamik, von,
Strom äh äh erziehen äh Strom, es ist alles, die die Gesetze von die wir kennen, von der Natur. Es ode, alle diese Modell sind,
realistisch kalibriert und wie sagt man? Skaled down, so.
Runtergeschrumpft sozusagen auf die richtige, ja.
Runtergeschrönt so ein bisschen. Aber sehr realistisch ist ähm kann man jetzt erwarten, dass es wirklich wie im echt.
Das heißt, man müsste.
Irgendwann auch mal in der Lage sein quasi so richtige Simulationen damit zu fahren. Ich meine ihr setzt doch in der Raumfahrt auch,
solche Software erhalten. Ich meine, im Prinzip ist ja die ganze Vorausplanung einer Mission. Ich kann mich erinnern, hier äh mit äh Elsa habe ich mal hier äh Bipicolumbo besprochen, was ja auch so eine unglaubliche Herausforderung ist, überhaupt.
Etwas erstmal bis bis zum Merkur zu bekommen, weil man halt diese außergewöhnliche Herausforderung hat, dass so ein,
totaler Miniplanet so äh direkt in der Nähe äh der Sonne, also maximale Grafitation, minimale Gravitation. Das äh ich glaube das Bild, was sie liefert, ist aber man muss halt irgendwie so eine Murmel,
zehn Jahre durchs äh Weltall äh schicken und dann äh versuchen in einer Schüssel,
so äh so hinzuschnippen, dass es mal kurz in so einer kleinen Kerbe hängen bleibt am Schloss. Und ähm auch das ist ja
Da kommt ja auch sehr viel Software hier zum Einsatz, die ja im Prinzip nichts anderes macht, die genau die tatsächliche Physik, die Gravitation, die Einführungskraft, Hitze, Atmosphäre, et cetera, all diese ganzen Dinge auch mit berechnet,
Ist das derselbe Ansatz wie bei äh Körbel.
Schon, aber bei uns, ich glaube, wir haben eine andere ähm Präzision. Wir wir gehen so mehrere ähm Nulls nach rechts.
Körper ist ein bisschen grob, ähm manche Modelle sind ein bisschen einfacher,
gebaut, um und das Gefühl zu geben, um das Prinzip zu zeigen, aber nicht nicht, wie gesagt, äh genau, weil sonst diese Person von den Spiell leidet darunter.
Ja, eure Simulationen dauern ja auch Wochen und Mona.
Unsere wir haben Zeit, wir wir können das mit Zeit planen, wir können unser Computer so ein paar Tagen laufen lassen, bis bis uns eine eine hochpräzise Ergebnis gibt,
Das ist der Unterschied. Wie, wie, wie präsis man geht mit Körbel und mit äh unserer Software. Und.
Kommen wir nochmal zu unserem Flug hier zur äh June. So, also jetzt starten wir äh diese tolle Rakete, die alle äh Feuchtungen und Features äh hat und oben sind noch die drei äh Kurbel, super äh Helden am Start, die alles mitmachen.
Bild, Valentine.
Und sich mit allem zufrieden geben.
Gut, sagen wir mal, der Start hat jetzt funktioniert und es ist noch nichts auseinander äh geflogen. Wie lange dauert denn jetzt sozusagen, dass äh also also wie lange sitzt man da und gleitet durchs Nichts.
Im Prinzip dauert's mehrere Tagen, Monaten sogar, aber man hat so einen Knopf, wenn man drückt und dann geht's schneller, weil im Weltraum,
du machst deine deine Manöver und zielst irgendwo und dann ist die die meiste Zeit.
Ist nur äh frei fliegen. Es ist nur äh balistisch, wie wie.
Ja. Mhm.
Wie eine Kanonenkugel. Du schießt einmal und dann das geht. Und diese Phasen kannst du.
Schnell gehen. Das sind die Phasen, die normalerweise Monaten dauern, die kannst du,
schnelle, schnelle, zehnmal schnelle hunderttausend, zehntausend und dann geht das nun bei, wenn du schon in der Nähe von deiner Ziel bist, dann gehst du zurück zur Normalzeit,
Und dann kannst du deine neue Manöver machen, Zielen, genau an dem Punkt, wo du rein äh kommen willst.
Bisschen auch als äh wie bei weitem Mission, wo man dann auch sagt, allein schon wegen Energie sparen, jetzt gehen wir hier mal drei Jahre in Halba Nation. Wir fliegen einfach nur durch die Gegend irgendwann wacht das Ding dann wieder.
Bei Köbel, alle diese Phasen hätten wir in zwei Sekunden durch. Hier haben wir für Roséte, äh es waren drei Jahren äh High Brenation und,
andere Satelliten brauchen sechs, sieben Jahren ihr Ziel zu erreichen und auf dem Spiel kann man. Außer wenn man in dem Spiel auch so elektrisch Antrieb benutzt,
was wir hier bei Bepicolombo haben, elektrischer Antrieb, da muss man ständig äh antreiben, ne. Das muss immer äh,
Weil das ist eine sehr, sehr geringe Kraft. Da muss man dann lang, lang diese diese Antrieb anhalten. Und in dem Spiel, wenn man das macht, da muss man auch.
Die ganze Zeit wart, aber nicht nicht äh Monaten wie äh es sind dann Stunden Stunden. Aber es geht da auch.
Gut, dann kommen wir jetzt irgendwie an bei unserem äh äh Planeten und hat man ja dann sozusagen dieses spezifische Problem, dass man ja dann richtig gezielt haben muss,
Also wenn man jetzt nicht genau mit der richtigen Geschwindigkeit an der richtigen Stelle zum richtigen Zeitpunkt ankommt, dann ist ja meistens schon alles vorbei. S.
Schon von Anfang an. Man man muss gucken, wenn man schon startet, dass die Planeten in die richtige Position sind, dass wenn man an den anderen vorbeikommt, er da es kann sein, dass er genau auf der,
gegenseitig ist, da muss man da schon von vorne an gucken, dass die Planeten in die richtige Position am Start sind.
Aber wie wird man dabei unterstützt? Also.
Gibt's so äh Tipps und Tools, was man äh finden kann, so wo soll Dune sein, wenn ich aus Kerbin gehe,
Und dann guckst du, gehst vorne mit der Zeit bis bis das Planet da ist und dann,
startest du dein, deine Rakete. In dem Moment. Und dann und dann, weil das alles ein bisschen so grob ist, als in echt einigermaßen kommst du dann mit mehr oder weniger Geschwindigkeit, ein Kilo mehr oder weniger Treibstoff,
kommst du immer da? Und ähm aber dann muss man schon ein bisschen wissen, wo wo muss alle diese Phasen so,
Und Staaten in erstmal in Umlaufbanden der Erde, dann zielen und dann diese diese lange Fahrt zum neuen Planet, dann wieder im Umlaufmann bringen und dann ein Landepunkt aussuchen,
und dann Geschwindigkeit äh,
runterbringen und diese Lande. Und alles, alles das ist in echte Zeit und da muss man mit mit tasten oder mit Joystick muss man das dann,
machen, fliegen. Das ist nun so ein neues Kill, was man dann lernen muss, wie man dann.
Da ist man dann wirklich Astronaut.
Ja, da ist man schon wie wie ein Astronaut. Da muss man schon bremsen und drehen und in welcher Richtung man jetzt,
feuert seine, seine Triebwerke. Das muss man dann schon diese neue Skill entwickeln.
Mhm. Und das geht wahrscheinlich auch tausend Mal schief, bevor man dann wirklich äh gelandet bekommt. Heute findet man dann irgendwas auf diesem Planeten, ist das dann so ein bisschen wie bei Star Wars, dass es da noch so eine Bar gibt, wo dann.
In äh bei bei der bei Mond, bei Mond,
ähm gibt's, gibt's ich weiß nicht, ob die noch sind, aber gab's so eine Statue von äh Niramstrong irgendwie, so ein Monument,
Gab's eine Stelle an der Karte, wo wenn man da rein kam, hatte man so eine Monument,
Ah, ich weiß. Das war ihnen genau in die gleiche äh Koordinaten als Ermstrong gelandet hat auf diese Punkt in in dem Spiel haben sie so ein so ein kleines Monument an an Armstrong.
In den Spiel gebaut hat. Könnte man das besuchen? Gibt's so ein.
Aber es gibt keine anderen Außerirdischen oder so. Also es gibt da jetzt keine noch nicht, das kommt alles noch.
Noch nicht, ja, noch nicht. Es kommt in Körbel zwei Komma null, dann kommt so kann man zu anderen Sonnensystemen fliegen und ich glaube, dann wird's wild.
Fehlt.
Leben und andere Sachen. Ich glaube, ich bin gespannt, was was dann kommt.
Aha. Okay, machen die Körbels dann irgendwas, wenn sie dann da sind, also so da sitzen die eigentlich immer nur brav rum und tun was. Also. Mhm.
Die haben immer eine Frage dabei? So die können immer ihre Frage hinstellen, wo sie landen und die haben so ein, so ein Jetpack im äh auf dem Rücken und die können so auch so ein bisschen spazieren gehen und fliegen ein bisschen,
es hängt davon wie wie groß die Schwerkraft ist auf dem Planet, wo du, wo du gerade bist, aber auf dem Mund, die können somit diese Jetbacks rumfliegen.
Können äh,
Roves steuern oder sonst nur nur Bilder machen, Selfies von sich selbst und das speichert man dann als.
Ich vermute mal, Strahlenbelastung ist noch kein kein Thema derzeit. Die halten alles aus, die Kurbels.
Ne, ne, noch nicht, ne? Die sind grün und stark.
Unverwüstlich. Okay. Und dann muss man jetzt quasi, um wieder zurückzukommen, muss man nochmal so eine Startphase äh starten.
Ja, ja. Muss man das schon vorher geplant haben. Aber im Echt ist es auch so, wenn man äh wenn man die Mondmission geplant hat, der Porlo,
Musste man auch von von ganz hinten nach vorne bauen. Man muss äh dieser Schritt ist normal in der in der Entwicklung von einer Mission.
Muss man, muss man so alles Schritte denken, was was braucht man an Treibstoffe, jede Phase und das muss man mitbringen.
Jetzt ist es ja so, dass äh die E, also NASA auch, aber äh auch die Esa mit Körbel so, weiß nicht, so eine Kooperation ist vielleicht soweit das Wort äh,
eingegangen ist, aber äh man kann jetzt quasi Esa Mission nachspielen.
Richtig. Die letzte Version von äh Körbe kam jetzt im Juni raus und äh dabei waren zwei Esermissionen. Bepicolombo und Rosette schon vorgebaut,
Und äh ich glaube sogar schon vorgestartet und da könnte man,
sie, wie wir hier machen, bis zum Ende diese Mission durchführen. Und dazu kamen Tipps von meinen Kollegen äh Kollegin Else hat,
viele Tipps von der von der Mission an den Entwickler gegeben und das kommt als Tool Tipps in den Spiel und da kann man was lernen auch über die Mission.
Aber wenn das jetzt schon vorgebaut ist, wo es dann noch die Herausforderung, als es dann sozusagen nur noch so zuschauen, wie es war oder muss man dann auch noch irgendwelche Herausforderung.
Man muss die fliegen, man muss dann ans Ziel kommen, steuern und,
als als diese Version raus kam, haben sie eine Aktion gemacht und mit zwei ähm professionellen Spieles haben sie die beide Mission geführt und ein Video gefilmt mit einer ähm,
Kollegin von uns dabei.
Mhm. Was ist die Mission der Welt? Mhm.
Die Mission erklärt hat. Und diese Videos stehen in YouTube und kann man sie sehen und da wird gezeigt, wie man diese Mission dann zu Ende,
fliegt. Eine warusierte und da muss man diese Länder bringen zum Komet,
Man konnte äh und in den Spiel kam tatsächlich ein Komet mit einer langen ähm Schweif, mit einem langen Schweif,
und da könnte man dort hinfliegen und diese Länder auf dem Boden,
bringen und in die andere Mition. Da fliegt man mit äh elektrische Antrieb bis Merkur. Da muss man in Umlaufbahn bringen und die japanische Modul dann im Umlaufband bringen und,
das gehört alles da zu der Mission.
Und sind da jetzt auch original Bilder jetzt von dem Cometen verwendet worden oder ist das nur so ein.
Das glaube ich nicht, das ist ein Modell, aber sieht, sieht ähnlich, sieht äh auch realistisch und schön.
Mhm. Und die NASA macht das auch.
Ich weiß nicht, ob die auch eine Kooperation haben. In diese Version war, was war nur mit Esel? Da kann auch spezielle Teile, so ein Arian fünf Modell und die Satelliten würden schon vorgebaut, aber sehr ähnlich. Die,
wie unseren. Aber mit die Teilen, die ins Spiel kamen schon.
Ich glaube, die Nase hat ähm was mit Astrid äh beigetragen schon. Relativ früh. Mhm. Jetzt frage ich mich.
Wenn man jetzt also was ja eigentlich Körbe ist, ist so ein bisschen so ein kreatives,
Mission selber zu planen. So, ne? Und dabei hat man äh eine ganze Menge Freiheiten, klar, man bewegt sich so grundsätzlich in diesem Grundgerüst von, was,
das, was hat man, Raketen et cetera, aber diese ganze äh Logik mit,
Wann fliege ich in welche Richtung und vor allem, was für Kette ich miteinander, was du ja schon angedeutet hast mit diesen ganzen Submissionen? Und gerade sich jetzt mal anschaut, so auf dem Mars, was da derzeit los ist.
Das ist ja, das sind wir ja eigentlich auch schon weg von dieser Vorstellung, dass so eine Mission immer so für sich ein Ding ist und dann geht's wieder zurück. Wenn man heute zum Maß fliegt, dann,
fahren da schon ein paar Rover äh rum, dann gibt's da irgendwie eine Batterie von äh Orbitern, die unterwegs sind, mit denen man ja Kooperationen machen kann. Da können Landepunkte,
werden verlorene Rover äh wiedergefunden werden. Man kann bestimmte Messungen von anderen äh Missionen machen lassen, um das dann wieder äh Einfluss nehmen zu lassen. Ich könnte mir jetzt so vorstellen, das ist jetzt so ein bisschen meine äh verrückte äh,
Denkfeld, wenn ich jetzt darüber nachdenke, dass jetzt einfach viele ähm,
Leute, die sich einfach spielerisch, vielleicht auch jüngere Leute halt äh auf Körbe äh einlassen,
einfach auch auf ganz andere Ideen kommen könnten, wie man Missionen miteinander verstrickt, in welcher Reihenfolge, welcher Dimensionierung man das macht, weil grad so immer diese Frage mit,
mach ich viele kleine, mache ich eine Große, das sind ja auch immer so die so ganz grundlegende Designentscheidungen die bei so einer Missionsplanung auch,
teilweise ein Jahrzehnt, zwei Jahrzehnte zurückliegen und dann irgendwann auch nicht mehr geändert werden können. Ähm,
hältst du das für für möglich, drängt sich das in gewisser Hinsicht an. Also ist das sozusagen so das Trainingstool, um auch einfach auf andere Ideen zu.
Ja, ich glaube schon. Ähm.
So alles was du im Körper baust, solange das nicht explodiert oder nicht zurück zur Erde gebracht ist, bleibt da. Alles, was in Umlaufbahn ist, so wie wenn du eine Raumstation baust, das bleibt im Umlaufband, wenn du da.
Aber nur in meiner eigenen lokalen Welt.
In einer hier in deinen lokalen Welt. Alle alles ist da und dann kannst du immer Sachen dazubauen. So, ich brauche jetzt eine Raumstation und von dieser Raumstation können meine Astronauten zum Mond gehen und von Mond können sie zu Maß und dann baue ich mein eine,
ein Dorf auf dem Mars und da lande ich viele kleine Häuschen oder kleine Kapseln, die so,
Ähnlich wie Häuschen sind und im Baum mir ein Dorf und dann will ich immer so,
hin und her mit meiner Scronauten gehen und dann neue Sachen bauen. Du kannst einen ganzen Welt und die bleiben da und die bleiben in Umlaufbahn und mit der Zeit.
Was sie machen, wird immer propagiert, wird immer.
Immer weiter getragen, ja. Mhm.
Tragen und das so,
Und im Prinzip kann man das als ein Welt benutzen, um um so neue Konzerte zu entwickeln. Äh ich ich würde nicht sagen, dass dass es bei bei Esel oder bei Nase so gemacht ist, dass nicht der Fall.
Weil dann gibt's viele Barriere, was im,
was etwas kostet auf Körbeltour, du kannst tausende Sachen bauen und es kostet nix, aber hier dann kommst du in der Grenze von Ressourcen und von von Kosten. Das muss man schon äh.
Auch noch berücksichtigen, ja. Aber das wäre ja auch ein Element, was im Körbel noch mit reinkommen könn.
Ist, es kommt, ne, es gibt ein Modul mit Karriere, da muss man auch an Geld denken und und das da hat man viele mehr Constrains in seine in seinem Wert. Aber um um nur so,
Konzepte, so wie wäre, wenn man.
Einfach andersrum macht, als wir es bisher gemacht haben, ja.
Ja, genau. Und nur um diese äh Ideen zu spielen und,
Und dann von diesen Konzepten, was man da spielt, irgendwann sagen, okay, wie wäre das dann im Echt? Was musste man dann Wäschetechnologie brauchen wir? Äh was sind die Probleme mit dieser Lösung.
Könne ich mich gut vorstellen. Das kann man,
weil da spielt viel die Kreativität, dass das wirklich man muss es ist ein Sandbox, das ist alles alles möglich, alles frei im Prinzip,
und äh und ohne diese Begrenzung kann man mit seiner Kreativität viel weit entfernt gehen.
Ja auf die Erde, man weiß, es gibt diese Technik und diese Technologie Technologie und damit bin ich.
Das ist mein Spielraum. Ähm mehr kann ich nicht mal. Und manchmal.
Ich glaube, er hat diesen Effekt. Und hat die Effekt, dass dass es bringt viele Leute an diesen Themen zu denken. Leute, die auch nix mit Weltraum zu tun haben normalerweise.
Oder noch nicht. Mhm.
Oder noch nicht und dann auf einmal mit die auf die Idee kommen, oh.
Und man sieht äh im Moment entwickelt sich die die Privatweltraumindustrie ganz stark,
alle alle Artenmissionen werden jetzt von von Privaten, von Universitäten, von Studenten, von Firmen,
im Moment gebaut und es wird immer einfacher das zu hinkriegen, so. Das hat eine Rolle.
Ja, du hast ja schon vorhin schon äh erwähnt, dass Basics eine ganze Menge
anders äh macht. Ich hatte äh hier bei Raumzeit auch äh in Raumzeit äh dreiundachtzig hätte ich mich mit Hans äh Königsmann unterhalten von Space X, der da sehr früher Mitarbeiter war und da haben wir auch sehr viel darüber gesprochen, dass
bei Space X eben
Dinge einfach auch generell anders zugelassen werden, dass man einfach sehr schnell auf neue äh Ideen und Anregungen eingeht und das alles eine sehr agile äh Entwicklung ist. Und das ist ja dann im Prinzip auch schon so eine.
Spielsimulation in gewisser Hinsicht innerhalb des Unternehmens, mit dem sie auch relativ Erfolg gehabt haben, weil sie halt auch das Scheitern quasi ähm,
akzeptiert haben, was ja oft ein Problem ist, auch so mental ist so, oh ja, was ist, wenn es schiefgeht? So äh in so einem Spiel ist dieses
schiefgehen, ja im Prinzip der Treiber. Man kann's halt die ganze Zeit schiefgehen lassen, so Fail ist einfach Part of the Game und in dem Moment äh kann man halt einfach mal frei spielen,
benutzt du ja auch Kurbel um andere Leute an dieses Thema äh Weltraum heranzuführen. Kannst du mal deine Erfahrung in dem Bereich ein bisschen schildern.
Ähm ich benutze es als als Tool ich kriege regelmäßig Praktikanten bei uns hier im Esock äh.
Wo kommen die her?
Aus aus hier, aus Darmstadt, äh aus der Umgebung, aus der hm Schule, ja.
Also Schüler. Mhm.
Zehnte Jahrgang oder elfte sechzehn siebzehn Jahre alt die müssen ihr Praktikum machen und manchmal kommen sie zu uns zweimal im Jahr normalerweise kriege kriege ich zwei Schüler in meine in mein Team,
und ähm ich erkläre sie in Theorie, wie man im Weltraum fliegt und was uns wie unser wir unser Satelliten in,
im Weltraum bringen und was sie machen. Aber dann kommt ein Punkt, wo ich das zeigen will und dann dann komme ich zu Körper und dann zeige ich die die, wie die, wie das von.
Von der Theorie in der hm.
In die Praxis übergeht. Mhm.
Und ähm ja da da ist der Spiel. Und vor kurz letztes Jahr haben wir gab's hier in der TU Darmstadt ein äh ein Turnament, ein Curble-Turnament. Wir haben so viele Teams und da habe ich meine Kinder mitgebracht, die die sind auch schon äh.
Begeistert und äh die machen das der jüngste sieben der Älste ist elf und der mittlere neun.
Und mittlerweile die sind schon Profis damit. Sie können schon ein Raket bauen und in den Weltraum bringen und in Umlaufbahn,
richtig. Und es ist sogar der Siebenjähriger, denn sie sind schon,
Da war ein Turnarment und da habe ich auch so eine kleine Präsentation, habe ich erste Missionen mit Körpermissionen vergleicht, weil ich habe auch schon mehrere von unseren Missionen auf Körper gebaut und äh,
Und äh so ähnlich gemacht und habe so so eine lustige äh zwanzig Minuten so Präsentation gemacht, wie das eben echt aussieht und wie das im Körbel aussieht und,
und äh ja und da haben wir mitgespielt und da gab's äh sogar eine Prämien für die besten Missionen da und ja, das hat.
Das war von der von der Studenten von der ähm Luft und Raumfahrt äh Abteilung in Theodor am Stand.
Die im Moment mit mit echten Satelliten beschäftigt sind mit Cubesatz und und mit Raketen,
und äh ja, das hat so eine wichtige Education äh Rolle auch.
Ja, ich meine, das ist super, wenn man so ein, so ein Tool äh hat. Meine, wir können jetzt nicht so viel über die neue Version äh reden, die angekündigt ist, ähm aber es ist eine angekündigt, also diese Version,
Du hast es schon erwähnt, ne?
Trailer habe ich gesehen, gibt's in YouTube mittlerweile man googelt Körbel zwei Komma null und kriegt diese Video.
Scheint mir dann nochmal so ein, so ein neuer Wurf äh zu sein, ne? Mit Interstellaren, Reisen und allen anderen äh Möglichkeiten und,
hab so ein bisschen so den Eindruck, dass da einfach so viel Druck dahinter ist, dass äh dass ich das eben so langsam eben auch wirklich in so ein richtiges,
Ja, ich will jetzt nicht sagen, Planungstool entwickeln kann, aber vielleicht nochmal so dieses Beispiel mit Bipi Columbo rauszubringen, also das,
Mission heißt ja nicht ohne Grund BP Columbo, weil halt der BP äh das eben,
der ja selber Missionsanalytiker war, äh überhaupt
auch erstmal auf die Dreh gekommen ist. Wie kombiniere ich jetzt nach einem Start diese ganzen Flybys, also wo muss ich überhaupt hinfliegen und hole mir von welchem Planeten jetzt
wie viel Energie äh das ist ja äh das ist ja nicht vorgezeichnet,
ja nicht klar, Alu, du hast ja auch gerade Rosetta äh erwähnt und eigentlich viele äh Missionen, die jetzt weit führen, insbesondere die halt auch sehr nah an die Sonne ranführen,
kritische Bremsphase ist, die man am Ende, also eigentlich will man ja sehr schnell dahin kommen.
Aber wenn man dann da ist, will man auf einmal nicht mehr schnell sein. So und wie wie kann man halt schnell sein,
und am Ende nicht mehr schnell sein ohne halt eine eine vollkommen irrealistische Bremsmasse quasi also
Treibstoffen mitzunehmen. Und das äh erscheint mir dann aber schon ein ganz interessanter Ansatz zu sein, halt einfach mit Körbel diese ganzen Dinge herauszuspielen und dann einfach auch irgendwo komplett neue,
Ansätze zu kommen, wie man irgendwo hinkommen kann.
Ja äh und äh dieser Flybye, diese hm Manöver ist mit äh Schwerkraft vom Planeten funktionieren im Körper. Man kann damit planen, man kann so ein kleinere Mission bauen und rechnen, dass man irgendwie.
Mond und andere Planeten benutzt, um irgendwo zu zu kommen. Das funktioniert auch.
So ein bisschen Space Billard, ne? Also.
Feldraumautobahn.
So, wenn jetzt irgendwie jemand äh unbedingt auch mal Körbe äh ausprobieren äh möchte, was aus was würdest du denn so äh äh raten, wie man da am besten einsteigt, wie man da, was man sich denn so als erstes für Ziele setzen sollte.
Ähm erst muss man das das.
Fliegen lernen. Okay, so wie komme ich in den Umweltraum? Wie bewege ich mich im Umwelt äh wie bewege ich mich im Umlaufband? Wie wie.
Äh das ist nicht logisch. Man man hat immer diese Idee von Star Wars, dass das ähm dass man ganz frei,
nach vorne, nach links, nach oben, nach unten geht und das gibt's ein oben, das gibt's an unten und im Feldraum ist es nicht wirklich so, wenn du in einen Planeten,
äh in Umlaufbahn bist, dann musst du ein bisschen anders denken,
Man macht seine Umlaufbahn ein bisschen größer oder ein bisschen kleiner und damit hat man mehr oder weniger Geschwindigkeit und damit kommt man näher oder oder entfernter von andere Objekten im Umlaufbahn,
und diese diese Art von Denken im Umlaufband muss man schon lernen und sich angewöhnen,
So das ist die erste Schritt wie ich hochkomme, in welche Richtung soll ich gehen, wie wie kriege ich wie kriege ich ähnlich ein Umlaufbahn,
Das muss man schon als erstes sich angewöhnen und lernen.
Bevor man jetzt auch irgendwie eine eine Rakete baut, äh erstmal quasi die Bewegung im All lern.
Schon mit danach Rakete. Da gibt's ein Tutorial, wie man ein einfaches Rakete baut.
Ja auch so die ganzen Standardraketen wahrscheinlich vorm Skretch oder?
Ja, also es gibt schon schon vorgebaut, gibt's welche. Kann man schon eins nehmen und und los losge.
Volk und neun und los geht's.
Ja, so ähnlich gibt's, das wäre die als Erste. Ähm,
und sonst einfach Kreativität mitbringen und aufs Team gehen, dass das Spiel runterladen, ein schon ein gutes Computer, dass es mit ein tolles Grafikkart um das zu genießen. Was es alles kann in Leistung,
und dann ja dann nix los vielleicht zu so einem großen Schirm was man die Sternen sehen kann und.
Du hast den YouTube-Kanal von dem Scott Mandy äh bereits erwähnt, gibt's noch andere äh Orte, wo man äh Hilfe holen kann, gute Foren.
Es gibt auch Deutschen ähm aber der Namen kommt mich mir jetzt nicht, aber es gibt auch eine deutsche Curble äh Profispieler.
Okay, das können wir dann in den Shownots noch nachtragen, ja. Mhm. Ich werde das zusammen machen. Mhm.
Ich werde das suchen und dann schicke ich.
Der macht im Prinzip genau das Gleiche.
Der ist genauso gut aber mehr für für die deutsche Community, aber der ist auch äh den Abko.
Nachdenken, dann fällt's dir ein.
Vierte kommt.
Ja, aber ist das schon so die primäre äh Quelle, an die man sich ranhängen sollte?
Videos, ein paar Videos gucken, da da kann man schon viel lernen in YouTube und es gibt so viele, so viele. Ist einfach Kurbel, Space Programm tippen und da kommen viele Videos und und dann probieren,
Man musste die Zeit nehmen. Das das muss man schon zwei, drei Stunden am Stück.
Am Anfange mindestens. Jetzt ich kann mich setzen und in zwanzig Minuten habe ich schon was Schönes gemacht und aber am Anfang waren's Stunden.
Hast du denn selber irgendwie was.
Entdeckt gelernt oder bist du selber schon in irgendeiner Form oft 'ne Idee gekommen die du vielleicht in deiner professionellen Arbeit in gewisser Hinsicht so noch nicht gesehen hast oder hast du schon noch den Vorsprung.
Man stellt sich immer so diese Herausforderungen und und da ist diese Element an Problemlösung.
Was Problem ist, was was noch nie du gedacht hast.
Und da musst du die eine Lösung finden und diese dieser Druck an,
eine einfache Lösung zu finden, was elegant ist und was schön ist, dass das was Neues, was man lernt, da.
Und das ist eine gute Übung auch für deinen Kopf, wie du mit Problemen umgehst.
Und das in in der Form von einem Spiel ist, ist sehr schön, es ist lustig an einer Seite, aber ist auch,
zufrieden. Man man hat diese,
Oh, das war elegant jetzt. Manchmal stelle ich mir vor, was wäre das kleinste Rakete, was ich im Umlaufband bringen könnte und zurückbringen? Was wäre das Kleinste, das Minimalste? Und dann ist man am am Optimieren,
Und diese Optimierungs äh Art von Denken gehört auch zu Weltraum, zu. Was ist das Minimum, was man braucht.
Um eine Ziel zu erreichen.
Mich erinnert das ja alles extrem an Programmierung an sich, am Computer,
Weil man hat's ja mit ähnlichen äh Dingen zu tun, ne? Man muss sich da auch so ein bisschen sein äh Rüstzeug äh zusammenstellen. Man muss vor allem auch mit den Ressourcen, die man hat umgehen und man hat eben äh tausend verschiedene Ansätze und äh wenn's nicht klappt, dann crasht es.
Ich würde das unter die Schirm von Kunst legen.
Kunst generell ist, wie man mit Kreativität eine Lösung findet unter Bedingungen,
wenn ich eine Bild malen will, dann stellen wir die Bedingungen, das soll in diese in diese Papier oder in diese,
mit diese Farben, mit diesem Material, da will ich ein Konzept herbringen auf diese mit diese Ressourcen. Und,
äh auf dem äh Raum von äh oder von,
Programmen entwickeln oder von von äh ein Roman schreiben oder ein Bild malen oder eine Opere oder ein Theaterstück, das das sind alle so,
Konzepte, was ein ein Mensch bringt vor von seiner Gefühle, von seine Erfahrungen, von seine Vorstellungen,
eine begrenzte Raum oder begrenzte äh.
Fällt und da muss man spielen, da muss man,
Seine Lösung finden und dann das begeistert jemand oder das oder begeistert sich selber in den in dem Fall vom Spiel,
wir haben wir haben öfter mit ich habe äh mit Kollegen dann gespielt und wir haben uns gegenseitig begeistert. Wir haben uns dann äh Bilder geschickt, Screenshots,
Hier guck mal, jetzt habe ich das geschafft und jetzt habe ich mit diese einfachste Lösung, habe ich das noch erreicht,
und ich das gehört alles unter dieser Schirm, was die Menschen,
Kunst bringt und zu zu seine Kreativität loszulassen. Es ist alles verbunden in meiner Sicht äh mindestens.
Mhm. So wie man. Ja und es gibt ja auch noch genug äh Herausforderungen, die äh kreativer Lösungen,
bedürfen, also wenn man zum Beispiel mal das Beispiel Weltraumschrott nimmt, ja? Wo es ja wo die Vorstellung von Mission auf einmal auch eine ganz andere äh wird, ja? Insofern wäre es vielleicht ja auch mal ganz,
schön, wenn wenn dieses Körbel sozusagen nicht immer nur, dass man nicht alleine ist
sondern dass man eben so eine so eine Art Share Curble Universe äh hat, wo man alle anderen äh auch gleichzeitig noch mit rumfliegen sieht. Ist natürlich ganz andere Herausforderung
auf die Berechnung davon, aber äh man kann ja quasi die ganzen anderen Objekte nehmen und wenn ich mir jetzt diesen ganzen Weltraumschrott, der äh herumfliegt, äh so nehme und dann eben Missionen baue mit, wie bekomme ich jetzt
diesen Schrott wieder auf die Erde zurückgeführt mit minimalen Ressourcen. Wie kann das sozusagen technisch äh funktionieren, damit es eben am Ende vielleicht auch überhaupt erst,
bezahlbar wird im äh im echten Leben, das.
Ist im Moment einer der größte Herausforderungen der Weltraum wie man diese Schrott-Interkontrolle bringt, die meisten nach unterbringen oder mindestens, dass wir wissen wo die sind und Konzepten dafür werden dringend nötig,
da kann man das im Spiel spielen, kann man sich viel Schrott im Weltraum bringen und dann Konzepten entwickeln.
Äh
Wie ist denn eigentlich die Kommunikation umgesetzt? Ich meine im realen Raumfahrtwesen hat man sehr viel mit Bodenkontrollstationen zu tun und man äh verwendet verschiedene
Kommunikationssysteme, man hat natürlich auch dieses Problem der Kommunikationslatenz,
wie ich das bisher immer rausgeführt habe ist so ja okay, wenn ich irgendwas steuere, dann steuere ich das quasi in Körbel immer sofort, so ich sage jetzt, du flixt jetzt irgendwie da lang
und und dann tut es das dann halt auch in dem Moment und klar, das ist das, was man irgendwie will, aber die reale Herausforderung ist ja, dass man dann halt wieder irgendwie am Heimarbeits
äh ist sozusagen auf seinem eigenen Planeten und dann neben diesen ganzen Kommunikationsdeleg ja äh auch noch mit reinberechnen muss, ne? So im Maß äh dauert's halt eine Viertelstunde, bis da eine Botschaft.
Das kommt nicht in.
Das ist noch nicht dabei.
Nicht dabei. Gibs Kommunikation, man kann ein Antenne mitbringen, weil das sieht auch gut aus und,
gibt so 'ne Modus wo man dann Wissenschaft sammeln muss und dann muss das zur Erde schicken, dafür gibt's Bodenstationen und Antenne, aber es spielt keine kritische Rolle an dem Flug,
Selbst da macht man alles in echte Zeit,
und äh ist man immer dabei. Da wo der Rakete ist, ist man auch da dabei, das ist nicht wie bei uns, wo wir alles äh.
Ferngesteuern gesteuert wird. Aber.
Gut, da ist noch viel Raum für Erweiterung.
Richtig. Kommt zu, auch was. Ja, aber das die kleine Unterschied. Wir arbeiten viel, wir planen vorher, wir machen äh und dann schicken wir diese diese ganzen Kommandos und Programmen zum Satulidung, der.
Führt das durch ganz alleine und autonom. Und bei bei Körbel macht man das äh jeder Kommando in Echtzeit.
Da ist man sozusagen selber der Computer.
Wie ich genau. Äh man ist dann die Kontrollelement. Ähm aber beim Spiel macht das mehr Sinn so.
Ist es spannende.
Ich sehe nur noch eine ganze Menge Potenzial, was äh quasi alles noch modelliert werden könnte äh in der Zukunft, was äh derzeit noch gar nicht dabei ist, aber halt so im äh echten Leben noch eine richtige Rolle spielt,
Ja
Ich denke, jetzt haben wir es ganz gut äh aufgerollt schon. Gibt's noch irgendeinen Aspekt, den wir äh vergessen haben äh bei der ganzen Aufzählung, der vielleicht noch der Erwinnung äh wert wäre.
Ja, ich glaube, wir waren ziemlich irgendwann gerade.
Umfangreich dabei. Ja, hast du vielleicht noch einen äh Tipp, wie man die Frustrations äh Momente.
Ich würde mich keine Sorgen machen über Frust, das hier und das.
Ja, ein bisschen Geduld braucht man, aber wenn man Lust da hat und wenn man das dann dann ist es einfach, gehört zum Spiel die Frustration,
und das das die Frustration macht einer noch süchtiger. Das jetzt schaffe ich das. Jetzt geht's. Ja, jetzt weiß ich.
Jetzt noch süchtiger.
Da kann man sich nicht loslassen. Das ist es. Ähm ja, ich ich wünsche alle neuen Spieler viel Spaß bei Körbe und viel Kreativität. Das ist das Lustige an diesem Spiegel.
Dann sag ich vielen Dank für die Ausführung hier zu deinem Leben und dein Spieleleben.
Danke für deine Fragen.
Ja kein äh Problem. Ja und ich sage äh vielen Dank fürs äh Zuhören hier bei Raumzeit und.
Heute geht aber bald wieder weiter. Wie es immer weitergeht bei Raumzeit.